they call me the tornado chaser when the
wind is up and conditions are right I
get in my car and follow violent storms
crazy is say perhaps but really I chase
these sky beasts to learn about them I
want to share with you what I know
tornadoes are rapidly rotating columns
of air that form inside storms then
connect with the ground via a funnel of
cloud when that happens they tear across
the earth posing a huge threat to life
and property because of this there's a
great deal of research into these
phenomena but the truth is there's still
a lot we don't know about how tornadoes
form the conditions that may give rise
to one tornado won't necessarily cause
another but we have learned a lot since
people first started recording tornadoes
like how to recognize the signs when one
is brewing in the sky are you coming
along for the ride tornadoes begin with
a thunderstorm but not just any
thunderstorm these are especially
powerful towering thunderstorms called
super cells reaching up to over 50,000
feet they bring high force winds giant
hailstones sometimes flooding and great
flashes of lightning - these are the
kinds of storms that breed tornadoes but
only if there are also very specific
conditions in place clues that we can
measure and look out for when we're
trying to forecast a storm rising air is
the first ingredient needed for a
tornado to develop any storm is formed
when condensation occurs the byproducts
of the clouds condensation releases heat
and heat becomes the energy that drives
huge upward drafts of air the more
condensation and the bigger the storm
clouds grow the more powerful those
updrafts become in super cells this
rising air mass is particularly strong
as the air climbs it can change
direction and start to move more quickly
finally at the storm space if there is a
lot of moisture a huge cloud base
develops giving the tornado something to
feed off later if it gets that far when
all these things are in place a vortex
can develop and close by the storm and
forming a wide tall tube of spinning air
that then gets pulled upwards we call
this a mesocyclone outside cool dry
sinking air starts to wrap around the
back of this mesocyclone forming what's
known is a rear flank downdraft this
unusual scenario creates a stark
temperature difference between the air
inside the mesocyclone and the air
outside building up a level of
instability that allows a tornado to
thrive
then the mesocyclones lower part becomes
tighter increasing the speed of the wind
if and that's a big if this funnel of
air moves down into that large moist
cloud base at the bottom of the parent
storm it sucks it in and turns it into a
rotating wall of cloud forming a link
between the storm that created it and
the earth the second that tube of
spinning cloud touches the ground it
becomes a tornado most are small and
short-lived producing winds of 65 to 110
miles per hour but others can last for
over an hour producing 200 mile-per-hour
winds they are beautiful but terrifying
especially if you or your town is in its
path in that case no one not even
tornado chasers like me
enjoy watching things unfold just like
everything however tornadoes do come to
an end when the temperature difference
disappears and conditions grow more
stable or the moisture in the air dries
up the once fierce parent storm loses
momentum and draws its tornado back
inside even so meteorologists and storm
chasers like me will remain on the
lookout watching always watching to see
if the storm releases its long rope
again
you